[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola buenas tardes algo así la
motivación que es algo que ha estado
presente en esta charla toda la tarde
entonces me pregunté qué significa la
palabra motivación así que busque la el
significado la etimología y la
motivación significa como viene del
latín moviendo movimientos motivos es
movimiento visión es acción entonces mi
charla la denomina motivar o movilizar
la acción con algunos ejemplos que les
voy a contar que creo que por ahí todas
las personas tenemos y no nos damos
cuenta si yo les pregunto a ustedes
quiénes creen que hay que cambiar cosas
en la sociedad que cosas que no nos
gustan querría que levanten la mano
y quienes de ustedes creen que tienen
las herramientas para realizar esas
acciones que no nos gustan y de las
cuales por ahí protestamos
en realidad lo que vamos a ver es que
muchos tenemos estas herramientas para
poder mejorar nuestro metro cuadrado
como podría ser este círculo si no
intentar hacer grandes cambios que quizá
aparecen muy lejanos pero si mejorar
nuestro día a día con las personas con
las que nos rodeamos
entonces tenemos que ver qué logramos
cuando nos motivamos tenemos muchos
ejemplos de motivación de deportistas de
músicos que tienen un logro personal al
lograr motivarse y lograr su meta y
alcanzar sus sueños lo que yo les voy a
proponer es quizás algo más comunitario
que logramos cuando nos motivamos y
motivamos a otros como nos motivamos
como logramos eso por ello uno lo dice y
es difícil de hacer y también para que
nos motivamos
entonces yo creo que esto es como una
reacción nuclear nosotros nos motivamos
hay alguna cuestión que nos inquieta
libramos de una manera diferente
empezamos a como la imagen lo ven chocar
otros átomos nos encontramos con otras
personas que empiezan a abrir vas a
vibrar de esta manera y se hace algo muy
contagioso muy descontrolado y logramos
los cambios que queremos como surge una
motivación
la motivación surge muchas veces de una
curiosidad en lo particular he sido una
persona curiosa desde chiquita me han
interesado muchísimas cosas como por
ejemplo los caballos
viví en un barrio frente a un club
hípico cada vez que se escapaba un
caballo yo decía listo este para mí
logré mi sueño acá lo tengo y no era tan
fácil bien que devolverlo tenía un dueño
y demás y no era como tener un perro o
un gatito que más o menos en un pequeño
espacio se puede desarrollar pero bueno
yo tenía un interés por los caballos me
fascinaban no sabía por qué entonces me
forjé un estudio dentro de la biología
me forjé esto y biología me encantaron
muchísimas cosas cuando tuve que decidir
una orientación me se me dificultó pero
bueno me recibí de bióloga me vine a
esquel y desarrollé mi formación con
bichos con insectos de pequeño tamaño
muchos años dedicados a estos organismos
sin embargo un día en la exposición
rural de una persona que hace otra cosa
con los caballos y dije bueno los
caballos no son para andar un paseo nada
más para la jinete baja hay otro mundo
que no conozco de hecho esa persona
comentó que los caballos servían para
hacer equinoterapia dije bueno que será
esto cuando la persona de esta cuenta lo
que es la equinoterapia a mí se me viene
a la mente mi papá mi papá hace 40 años
sufre un accidente que estaba en silla
de ruedas y de escucha si mi papá
hubiera tenido esto hubiera podido
mejorar su calidad de vida
en esquel tenemos que poder lograr hacer
equinoterapia entonces deje de hacer
recursos de bichos y demás cosas para el
doctorado para otras formaciones y
empecé a hacer cursos de temas de
caballos en algunos de estos cursos tomé
contactos con beneficios de los caballos
que yo no sabía ni que existían porque
la keynote era que está documentada se
sabe muy bien como ayuda a las personas
con discapacidad sobre todo con los
efectos motrices
pero los caballos me mostraron otras
cosas que realmente se me pusieron la
piel de gallina la ciencia no me las
explico las
y son nuestro espejo del alma y esto
tiene que esto lo tiene que poder hacer
todo el mundo ahora como empezamos a
generar esta actividad
bueno dije listo me dio me regalan un
caballo tengo un caballo y ahí empiezo
generado un valor de solidaridad con los
demás pero bueno estaba vibrando en esa
sintonía entonces se armó una armamos
una manada de caballos y también
hablamos la manada de personas vibrando
así me encontré con soledad que
estudiaba en la universidad con andrea
que era una kinesióloga y manuel y
nosotros 4
seguimos vibrando de esta manera y
hicimos nuestra manada de caballos
nuestra manada de personas y dijimos
esto lo tenemos que poder hacer nos
damos energía esta energía mutuamente es
así que tuvimos que ponernos a estudiar
cómo se hace una fundación cómo sería un
marco legal qué es lo que hace falta
hace falta caballos monturas
equipamiento saber de caballos y hacen
falta más personas en aumento nos
largamos a hacer la actividad
diseñamos un logo un logo con la
identidad propia con el nombre del
primer yegua que conseguimos para hacer
equinoterapia que es el lucero de sarro
la torta también hacemos de diseñadora
hacemos de todo
con esta actividad
nos llenamos nuestros corazones uno se
da cuenta que se motiva motiva a otros y
a su vez eso se retribuye eso vuelve a
uno mismo logramos juntar más gente
empezamos a trabajar
empezamos a trabajar con personas con
discapacidad y ahí nos convertimos en
motivadores de estas personas porque
logramos que las personas hagan cosas
que no pensaban que iban a poder hacer
como subirse un caballo y le empezó a
cambiar la vida a las personas aunque no
les parezca por ahí muy grande pero a
veces algunos niños con los que tratamos
sonríen cuando vienen equinoterapia o
están esperando ese día o dijeron sus
primeras palabras en equinoterapia son
personas que habitualmente tienen en un
consultorio muchísimo muchísimo trabajo
que hacer y esta actividad les permite
vincularse con este hermoso animal desde
otra forma entonces fuimos multiplicando
nos
llenándonos de amor llenándonos de más
gente también nos llenamos más de
caballos porque bueno pudimos crecer
gracias a estas energías
entonces es lo que estamos haciendo
vibrando y conectándonos con los demás y
logrando y encontrándose con gente que
vibra como uno a veces hay bajo bajo
neos o algún problema y otro vibra y te
contagia de nuevo y seguís seguís así
nosotros llevamos ocho años trabajando
en esto
formamos pedimos capacitaciones a los
demás como ustedes ven siempre las caras
son de felicidad y multiplicamos
multiplicamos todas nuestras acciones
con el clima que todo que si vivimos en
esquel una zona patagónica así que la
mayor parte de las veces hace mucho frío
hay que ir a hacer actividades con los
caballos al aire libre y no es un
impedimento
entonces yo dije bueno esto es esto es
uno de los ejemplos que yo les voy a
transmitir y el otro
es como que le pude dar forma a cosas
que me pasaban en nosotros ámbitos de
desarrollo que es la universidad
y realice cursos de programación
neurolingüística ahí me di cuenta que
nosotros todos nosotros tenemos en
nuestras manos el poder de modificar
nuestra vida y somos los responsables de
todo lo que ponemos acá adentro las
cosas buenas y las cosas malas una de
las primeras cosas que me di cuenta es
que lo que nosotros decimos es lo que
genera el pensamiento que tenemos
y la forma en la que hablamos es algo
una de las primeras cosas que yo quiero
bastante cuando pude adquirir estas
herramientas y dije esto tiene que
servir para más es así que dije vamos a
motivar a otra gente a los estudiantes
porque se me dio esta inquietud de
motivar a los estudiantes en la
universidad porque empecé a escuchar por
los pasillos no quiero no puedo no voy a
aprobar el parcial no sé soy y realmente
dije no no podemos estar hablando de
esta forma y es algo que no se enseña es
algo que no aprendemos innatamente y nos
genera miedo
generalmente el sistema educativo es
algo muy formal no se estandariza nos
pone a todos iguales y sobre todo hay un
autor del libro de los cuatro acuerdos
que dice que el sistema educativo de la
de la domesticación está estudiado
científicamente en la cantidad de no que
se le dice a los niños muchísimos no que
hacen no te subas no esto cuidado con lo
otro y van moldeando personalidades que
tienen miedo después hay también entendí
porque mi mamá nunca me dejaba ir a
bailar yo le decía mamá no me dejas ir a
bailar y no ya estaba en la realidad
creada así que sirve para muchas cosas y
esto
planifique un taller utilizando este
mismo miedo como atrayente entonces como
el miedo era rendir dije cómo rendir un
final sin morir en el intento bastante
drástico ya no lo uso más los próximos
van a tener otros nombres más positivos
con que me encontré con una aula magna
llena un sábado de la tarde dos de la
tarde después del partido del mundial
nunca esperé que los jóvenes quisieran
ir y 18 había jóvenes de la universidad
de otros institutos que tenían esta
inquietud que algo tenían que hacer con
sus temores así que les voy a contar
algunas técnicas sencillas que
utilizamos para poder modificar esto que
nos pasa en nuestro entorno en el que
cada uno se encuentra
lo primero es analizar que nos decimos
dijimos que la palabra es muy importante
que nos decimos o cómo nos escribimos y
lo que fluye o lo que sale al toque en
los jóvenes y en nosotros mismos también
porque todos tienen celular antes
preguntaron fíjense qué cantidad de
mochis tenemos positivos y qué cantidad
demos y si tenemos negativos entonces si
no nos vemos con otra persona cara a
cara para que vea mi expresión vamos a
llenar nuestra conversación de cáritas
tengo miedo gusto en frutado toda esta
fila que está ahí abajo mejor no te digo
estoy enfermo por dios millones de
representaciones gráficas que nos ponen
en un tono negativo
además también empecé a ver en los
estudiantes que en sus redes sociales
usaban memes y todos usan para decorar
la vida de uno tanto en whatsapp como en
facebook en todas las redes
qué cosas aparecían en los memes que
usaban los estudiantes aparecían una
colección de hecho de de frases que son
bastante dramáticas así que se las pedí
para coleccionarlas y usarlas en los
exámenes y perdón en las talleres y
poder destacar esto
que buscaran algunos meses positivos no
encontraron tuve una alumna a romina que
inventó uno dijo 'no tan positivo como
un protón y lo puso en su perfil
entonces también destacamos con los
chicos que es importante llenar nuestra
vida de las cosas como queremos que sean
no como no queremos que sean sí
y otra cosa hicimos también nuestra
mente trabaja con una percepción de
nosotros mismos estos miedos que
decíamos son miedos culturales no sólo
tenemos un miedo biológico yo siempre lo
llevo a la ciencia que es mi otra parte
muy importante a que el mío de
supervivencia a que no nos coma un puma
por ejemplo tenemos que sobrevivir pero
el otro miedo que tenemos producido por
todos los que metemos en la educación
nos son miedo al qué dirán a que van a
pensar de mí a qué van a pensar de mí
todos ustedes cosas que en realidad uno
no puede manejar entonces tenemos que
trabajar con nuestra propia imagen
mental y no en alguno de los libros con
más falta lo muestra esto muy
gráficamente cuando está el gerente del
banco muy grande y el señor que lo va a
pedir se siente así de chiquitito
entonces que hicimos con los chicos les
enseñé a chicas a los profesores tenían
que ir a rendir entonces bueno agarran
el profesor al tendrán o lo agarran de
verdad en su mente hacemos este
trabajito de achicarlo entonces lo que
yo a chico
si es algo que se aleja
la próxima entonces lo que me da miedo
me atemoriza lo achicó se aleja de mí y
ya puedo trascender esta situación sin
ningún problema son algunas de las
técnicas que utilizamos con los chicos y
de hecho para no me han pedido que demás
estos talleres pero nosotros sirvieron
para motivar a los estudiantes también
sirvieron para motivar a los adultos
mayores también trabaje con autos
mayores y aunque hay muchos que están
muy motivados aunque uno no lo crea me
enseñaron también muchas cosas
lo que yo vi es que podemos motivarnos a
cualquier edad
también surgen valores de solidaridad de
compañerismo también podemos motivarnos
para luchar por nuestros derechos es
otra de las cosas que podemos hacer
entonces tenemos que querer podemos y
nos lo merecemos así que yo los invito a
que ustedes sean una reacción en cadena
a que no nos quedemos quejándonos de lo
que no nos gusta hagamos algo para
modificar y tener la vida que deseamos
tener muchas gracias
[Aplausos]